hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to prison architect
okay we got to find the drugs because
there's a lot of drugs going on here and
I don't know what kind of profit this
whole organization could have possibly
made why is this still not powered I did
good on get power to that oh it's not
built yet okay nevermind then we're good
it's fine everything's fine okay so I
need to get um more guards to help speed
up the search but the search is almost
done I mean I didn't even have to make
these get wow that is a lot of drugs oh
my goodness they've just got oh I
thought the janitors recurring bags of
drugs like that was just cocaine in the
bag I don't know what drugs are I don't
know what's going on hey how's it going
everybody welcome to the party oh you be
this guy doesn't even have a name
his name subject zero is a notorious
criminal whose crimes include piracy
kidnapping vandalism and murder she is
also a biotic possibly one of the most
powerful human biotics alive why oh oh
of course it's a Mass Effect reference
duh how can I get that maybe cuz it
doesn't look anything like Jack from
Mass Effect
oh no idea that's amazing good that's
cool then this must be Jason the
squirrel Astin went completely nuts in a
candy store with a 12 year old boy stole
the last pack of the chocolate-covered
peanuts your portal II show knows
reports after biting 47 big bean Wow
okay then alrighty that might be a
reference to someone but I'm not 100%
sure so I apologize if I don't know but
anyway we're gonna hire more guards
because we need to get this done
Oh boink boink boink boink boink okay
that should be enough and that should
speed up the process probably more
guards than we need but we still seem to
be making a profit which is the most
important thing in this so now we just
need to speed it up so our guys can
actually do what they need to do if
they're doing anything at all how do I
search all of the go
shakedown option where's the shakedown
chick down yeah search underway oh that
is cool that's Oh God
well that's too many things oh I'm sorry
Wow okay on the positive it's not as bad
as it could have been but there are
definite problems with the drug and
alcohol dependency what about all the
weapons there was knives shears blunt
objects probably poisonous substances
probably dildos that have been
weaponized we need to help these men
it's the only way of curbing their
activities in dealing with their
symptoms start a drug treatment program
in the infirmary our doctors will
administer a chemical substitute that
will help alleviate the cravings in our
addicts that's awfully heartwarming and
nice I thought you were gonna come and
tell me to build more electric chairs
for the alcoholics there isn't a
chemical substitute so I suggest we
start with group therapy sessions you
all have y'all y'all have to build a new
common room to run those meetings to
start new programs go to reports in the
bottom right of the screen then programs
anytime you're unsure what to do
highlight the objective and blah blah
blah we got this gun okay so the
shakedown is going on but we have
programs there we are so workshops
safety a bunch of people interested
pharmacological treatment and drug
addiction not a lot alcohol groups for
in-kyu so we need to start that no
regime timeslot they said we needed to
create a common room so I'm assuming I
can just build what maybe just maybe I
could just build this whole thing up
right here and connect it to the other
area now I'm probably enough be an
efficient use of space wouldn't it well
I got to clear those trees out of way
but who needs trees it's a prison not an
arborist what was that Wow are those
bags of blood I hope those are liquor
bottles but those are definitely poison
bottles right next to it
five cellphones six conscription bottles
that is a lot of stuff there's a lot of
stuff I feel like the escapists taina is
inner playing inside of this and they're
all having their own adventures while me
I'm just
I'm sure I ruined their day and they're
never able to go anywhere oh wow they
got handcuffed okay that was about all
the places that you could possibly
search I imagine I don't know how much
more we can find but we found about
everything so we need to start a drug
treatment plan as well
pharmacological okay so we got both of
those but I'm gonna what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna build this room up and then
we're gonna segment it into two
different areas so it'll be two
different things at once so materials
we're gonna have a we're gonna have a
concrete whoa whoa what the hell is that
why is that there there was supposed to
be a wall there who [ __ ] get that out of
here not that whoa not that okay so get
that out of there actually probably that
I don't think that needs to be there get
rid of that hope they didn't destroy
anything no it's fine it's all crap
that's probably fine this is build
another pipe to connect the two of those
since that didn't have any other
connections okay so now we need to build
walls to separate everything this will
be a brick wall cuz it kind of goes with
the theme out of boom and then we need
to create power connections all that
jazz fun fun stuff we don't need that we
need electrical cables to be able to run
through here for then
wait no okay that should be enough to do
that why is this locked block from what
Oh block from what point it's not
blocked what are you talking about it's
not blocked it's all electrical cable
who failed one time yeah whatever you
guys are doing it okay so we need to
build walls now so that's got a brick
wall oh it needs door I need that right
door door door door door door we need a
door door door door door is important
door is important we need the door in
here here here boink and boink boink
okay is it just gonna be two separate
rooms in there as soon as they install
the doors up then they get what they
need to do
why has their garbage in the way of the
goddamn door
get the garbage outta there they're
garbage right there geez get rid of that
whatever they'll figure that out I hope
anyway yeah they're okay so now I need
to build another wall to separate the
interior these into two separate rooms
poink okay so that's gonna be two
different areas with ability to go in
and out of each wound just like that and
that and then never the two shall meet
and actually that's how I want it so
we're gonna have the different rooms in
here we're gonna have a common room and
here why couldn't it be built there at
there I don't know why okay and right
there so we got the common rooms enabled
and then we're gonna put some more nice
wooden tiles in these we want people to
feel welcome and happy and I still don't
know why the walls are build properly
right there now we need to create a
meeting place made up of eight chairs
okay
does it just do that all right okay
there we go
that's not very organized and I don't
think that's exactly what I need to do
but it's good enough because that's
gonna be able to hey how's it going
there
very good we've made a real difference
here and I think the prison is back
under control a little bit not quite
hundred percent you can stay and improve
the prison further or we can move on to
the next facility when you're ready to
move on click on the Polaroid in the
infirmary you know what I'm gonna move
on because if we're just gonna go to
another prison anyway there's no reason
to stay here boy okay let's see what
happened to the dawn did he die like he
predicted he would I'm not 100% sure
about that oh oh it's Villa villa villa
Lake at Villa Blanca Villa Blanca Blanca
I don't remember what is she doing oh I
think I left the shakedown on I probably
should have let them all go free but
they are prisoners so hello Battaglia I
was close
I've Italia how you doing welcome here
this is awfully sinister music for
whatever the hell is happening over here
Battaglia yeah he probably knows that he
started the fire so that's probably
gonna be bad sweet cheeks I'm sorry I
[ __ ] up hush now
they said Pop's won't last the week I
know I came to say goodbye
you know we could walk away now you and
me this [ __ ] life it's taken
everything I'd like that but I can't I'm
a Palermo Nico I knew this was coming
with Papa gone and you and outsider in
this place our enemies would walk right
over this family I can't have that I
have to show them a Palermo still sits
on the throne
what so you here to [ __ ] whack me
after all we've been through Niko Niko
Niko
you're so old school no sweetheart I'm
divorcing you
Oh Oh that's actually an interesting
twist the [ __ ] you kidding me I'm a dead
man in here without the family behind me
I know sweetheart
but that's not my concern anymore oh wow
as an interesting twist I wish you to be
a I wish you to a better place Pappy oh
don't mind of me as I walk right over
your bed oh that's interesting
goodbye Nikko Oh Chapter three gobbles
GA BOS i don't know what that means
gabba gabba gabba whoa CNBC reporting
live from somewhere there where there's
a prison riot at alchemic Oh of
chemicals state prison staff and
security have withdrawn to the perimeter
to wait for military assistance a number
of personnel are still unaccounted for
including company CEO Charles Wallace
Brian II erupted following the arrest of
several high-profile judges alleged to
have taken kickbacks in return for
imposing harsher prison sentences Oh
Douglas Benedict currently serving a
life term is believed to be the
ringleader behind the outbreak of
violence adding fuel to the fire sources
say the criminal underworld has recently
been rocked by a series of high-profile
murders including the attempted
assassination of mob boss Victor Palermo
last month city mayor Calvin Heller
released his statement just a few
moments ago to those who questioned our
policies of punitive reform that should
act as a stark reminder these men have
been housing and food provided the
privilege of paid work this is how they
reward the taxpayers who subsidized
their comforts CEO Charles Wallace
deputy a relative newcomer to the post
has been tasked with restoring order it
has yet to be seen whether a lack of
experience will prove costly during this
difficult crisis
Oh Oh God oh geez oh well this is bad
honey no it's gonna be wow the
negotiators calling a my trap dinner Oh
God
okay oh geez hello they're all
unconscious holy crap it's out of
control here nobody is in charge we've
got multiple casualties and the
remaining guards won't go into the
rioting cell blocks we've had to pull
back to the perimeter figure out what to
do and put a stop to this before it gets
out of hand
riot police should be here in a few
minutes okay well I don't know what to
do how would I know what to do
everything's going to [ __ ] there's fires
everywhere oh my god stop the right oh
wow I don't know how oh geez oh geez oh
gosh oh gosh oh gosh I don't know I
don't know what to do
how do deployment Oh emergencies ah fire
engine
we need fires out first I guess we need
that maybe and let's the riot or so just
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of the
firefighters I don't know if that's
gonna happen but we can't let the fire
rage or otherwise it's just gonna be bad
all around to go there if you can oh no
they can't they can't even get inside
okay well tell you one cell block at a
time maybe I don't know if any of the
police are gonna actually go in I don't
know if they can no damn it I don't know
what to do oh here we go there oh we
were waiting on the riot police the
first the first other response teams
have arrived
these guys are riot guards and they're
much more heavily armored use these guys
to start retaking the captured prison
wings we've also got some paramedics
from the nearby State Hospital I suggest
you use them to give emergency medical
attention to your riot guards as they
would take the prison okay we're all
gonna go as one now let's not include
these guys all right we're all gonna go
as one no we're good goodbye I'll call
you when I need you
let's go for it whoops [ __ ] all right
let's go for it let's go let's go all
right we got paramedics and rygaards
we're going in maybe the maybe the
paramedics would also like to go treat
these guys all right let's go in we're
taking one block at a time very slow and
methodical and make sure that we got
everything
counted for are they actually gonna be
doing in together doing something okay
so those guys are healing those guys up
so we need to go right into this wing
here so we'll start by going over there
so far so good
make your ways in there at least I'm
still getting paid for this that's
awfully nice doesn't sound like good
things are happening there's a lot of
people that are dying in there which is
bad okay so you guys treat that but when
they get all healed up I'll bring him in
and then we'll grab everybody either
oh there's fighting okay good I guess
did we do it
whoo geez okay we'll start with this
cell block well maybe these guys
shouldn't be here I'm beginning to think
that maybe they're we're not supposed to
be there they're probably not supposed
to be there oh we got to retake you know
that's why okay they're good well that's
fine sorry sorry I have to do that bang
boom bang boom okay so now get this one
are these cops ready to roll yet these
guards okay these guys are ready to roll
get over here aw cannot enter right oh
jeez okay well we'll start retaking
order about staging them in the non
rioted area at least okay these guys
will go in there move it okay moving in
okay so far so good I'm gonna bring
let's see I'm bringing this guy oh good
okay they're getting medical attention
why don't they sound like robots when
they're moving around moving forward
forward what are you doing you leave
them alone alone alright we're good
we're good we're good
controlling control and I don't know why
I'm being so strategic about this but
I'm just a little worried oh here we go
more riot guards have arrived perfect
exactly what I needed because we got a
situation going on over here
get in there get in there buddy boos
you're on your own you're on your own in
this heavily guarded wing which looks
very bad get in there and get them good
smash them up break them down all right
hopefully this will be okay okay I'm
gonna send two of these guys over to
join the other Rygaard so we'll have two
paramedics to each group hopefully once
they're done doing whatever the hell
they're doing
mayor Calvin Heller is calling okay I
assume this is the CEOs deputy with whom
I'm speaking I appreciate this is a very
difficult time and we're all under
intense scrutiny rest assured you have
my full support and using any and all
resources at your disposal we've gained
a foothold and retaken some of the
prison and a loss of life so far is
completely justifiable but before you
push on to retake the rest of the prison
Yuri secured the wings that you have
captured hire some guards and assign
them to the recaptured sectors from the
deployment screen they will ensure the
captured wings stay captured once you've
taken care of that pushing into the
remaining zones and put these monsters
down these animals can't be
rehabilitated and they can't be
negotiated with I'm working on
authorizing an armed response team that
will put an end to this quick that seems
a little bit extreme I'm not a hundred
percent sure about that but maybe oh
hello
the mayor is brought in some armed
police from the nearby police station oh
boy but that seems extreme be careful
with these guys you might just end up
with a bloodbath on your hands if you
let them loose on the other hand the
prisoners may choose to surrender when
they see these guys coming in well yeah
that's like is that optional is that
optional if I use these guys do I have
to use these guys because that seems
like it might be a little bit extreme
these guys over here what are they doing
in there get in there get in there you
guys need to go you guys need to move
alright so these guys over here are
doing their jobs so if it's good so we
just need to enter here we need to take
a moment for them to heal up and that
this fire is out of control holy [ __ ]
that is bonkers I don't think there's
any saving that that is just done for
holy crap okay so these guys are gonna
push in from the south side so they can
come in here hello
you've got wounded all over the prison
and more to come no doubt you can't just
leave them to bleed to death
building infirmities somewhere on the
site and hire doctors to treat the
injured we've also seen quite a few
bodies for the sake of their dignity we
need to build a morgue and start
collecting them up you'll need to hire
some workmen to do the construction work
be sure to keep them safe well I this
seems like a bit of an extreme thing to
do in the middle of a riot why would we
bring construction crews who have
nothing to do with prisons at all over
into this area
oh man that doesn't seem good at all but
whatever it is what it is can't fight no
point okay so I'm gonna subdivide that
into two different rooms and then work
with that there and then as soon as
these guys decide that they're stop
being giant babies push in push in come
on push you in where you go where you
guys not pushing okay and then these
guys need to go in here okay who's
calling yes the main bulk of the
reinforcements have arrived you can now
call up as many squads of riot police
and paramedics as you need from the
emergency toolbar
okay emergencies riot police and
paramedics bring them in oh Benedict
why is Benedict how did he get a number
oh boy that ain't good listen up we've
got your CEO oh that's not good oh boy
oh jeez yeah so this is how it works I
ask you give any problems send anyone in
or if I even smell a cop
I could have bullet in his skull we want
an unmarked vehicle blacked-out windows
full tank one hour I'll be in touch well
that's a lot of demands Oh slam drama
well this is quite a situation that
they've gotten themselves into
really barricaded in there oh boy that
ain't good oh boy this is completely
unacceptable we need eyes on that
canteen so we can see what's happening
there's a small security room to the
north of the canteen we need to secure
it deploy some guards in there to the
man
the CCTV console and we'll get vision of
the whole cell block okay you got it I
need to capture that real quick getting
it I'm on it I'm on it baby
yes let's take a look at the hostage
situation oh this is bad this is more
than I thought would come out of prison
architecture last chance to walk out of
here boss man never play two ball tag oh
geez I've never played two ball tag two
bullets four empty chambers used to play
this with jack rabbits we blow their
heads clean off it's not really a game
when it's just killing things doesn't
seem too fun but you'll work just the
same let's start with a simple question
what were you doing in that office Oh
oh no I swear I don't know anything
burning something I see my own
reflection enough to know a man doing
wrong oh boy
fine who goes first you me what about
this guy
oh geez what do you know it's just like
a jackrabbit Oh what was in those vials
Wow
I swear I don't know looks running out
still a blooded and bullet in there
somewhere and I know what I saw
couldn't believe my own eyes the big
company man himself here in my prison
looking guilty as [ __ ] I'm guessing
there was more in those files in just my
rap sheet please please don't
odds are getting shorter Wallace
yeah it's probably gonna be blanks all
the way up to Wallace I tell you what
I'll make it easier for you oh well
that's that's not even that's just a
logical probability if it's bullet then
there's two empties and then there's a
bullet alright enough with this [ __ ]
yeah there's there's a bullet right here
if I know how to play this game and I
think I do it's your turn [ __ ]
unless you tell me what I want to know I
can't please no jeez okay please please
don't shoot it was money it was all
money that's it you're valuable
commodities the longer any of you are in
here the more profit we make we were
just bending the rules that file was the
proof so what are we worth what do you
get for keeping us inside seventy-three
thousand dollars a year per person
that's a lot of money jeez that's more
than average salary each son-of-a-bitch
time for you to start paying back oh boy
oh boy that's no that's not good oh
that's not good okay I need to go excuse
me I need to go think about workers and
such guys get to work don't worry about
the riot it's fine to worry about school
it was fine Doris fine okay so I need to
put these guys in here
Oh that guy's dead I didn't know that
guy died holy crap I had no idea okay
but higher guards and deploy them to the
recaptured zones okay I've done that
these guys are working in there oh
there's only two left holy crap oh
that's no good that's no bueno
well that's no bueno well might as well
hire some janitors ah yes
clean this up into our janitors that's
the only thing that I'm worried about
okay so we got more reinforcements over
here anyway so let's get Oh let's just
get everybody we need to get everybody
in there let's get them at least in here
get these guys in here
all those guys didn't
oof oof cuz the other guys work in these
guys are working in its eventually
they're gonna work into here we're gonna
hire more staff guards for here guards
for here okay
it's of course of GU Dan I forgot
right-click also does that okay move in
there oh boy
so we got to get to the outside of the
canteen the max security Wing is where
we're working on right now and then the
bulk of the group is coming over there
so I'm just gonna speed it up so we can
get this done oh jeez staff okay now
push in here there we go push in push in
get it all right we got a good okay
good police guards doing their thing
cookers in there okay okay so this is
just desolate this just needs to be
destroyed this is all just dead and
actually I'm actually out of time for
this episode so man that we're gonna get
to the bottom of this in the next
episode I don't know when but we're
gonna get there and holy crap this is
going nuts but hopefully everything will
be in order very soon but I have no idea
how that's gonna work but either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how to solve this problem in
the comments below thanks again
everybody and as always I'll see you
there's no way to see them if that
sounds good